en el síndrome del corazón izquierdo
hipoplásico el lado izquierdo del
corazón de un bebé recién nacido no se
ha desarrollado en su totalidad
el corazón es un órgano muscular
encargado de bombear la sangre que
contiene el oxígeno y los nutrientes que
el cuerpo necesita
las secciones de bombeo del corazón son
la aurícula derecha
el ventrículo derecho
a la aurícula izquierda
y el ventrículo izquierdo
en un corazón normal la sangre con bajo
contenido de oxígeno fluye desde el
cuerpo a través de venas grandes
denominadas vena cava superior y vena
cava inferior hacia la aurícula derecha
luego la sangre se dirige hacia el
ventrículo derecho el que se contrae y
envía la sangre a los pulmones a través
de la arteria pulmonar
la sangre captura oxígeno en los
pulmones y vuelve a través de las venas
pulmonares a la aurícula izquierda y
luego ingresa al ventrículo izquierdo
por último el ventrículo izquierdo se
contrae y envía sangre rica en oxígeno
al cuerpo a través de la aorta
antes del nacimiento el corazón no envía
sangre a los pulmones para obtener
oxígeno ya que el bebé aún no respira
en su lugar todo el oxígeno que el bebé
necesita pasa de la sangre de la madre
al bebé a través de la placenta y el
cordón umbilical
además la sangre que proviene del
corazón del bebé rodea los pulmones de
dos maneras
una es a través de una conexión entre la
arteria pulmonar y la aorta llamada
conducto arterioso
la otra es a través de una abertura en
la pared entre las dos aurículas llamada
foramen oval
estas aberturas adicionales permiten que
la sangre rica en oxígeno rodee los
pulmones del bebé e incluso circula a
través del cuerpo
por lo general uno o dos días después
del nacimiento el conducto arterioso y
el foramen oval se cierran
lo que fuerza a la sangre del bebé a
viajar a los pulmones para capturar
oxígeno en el síndrome del corazón
izquierdo hipoplásico el corazón de un
bebé recién nacido tiene graves defectos
de nacimiento que impiden que la sangre
fluya normalmente hacia el resto del
cuerpo si el cuerpo no puede obtener
oxígeno ni nutrientes no puede
sobrevivir el ventrículo izquierdo que
es la bomba principal y la aorta que es
el conducto principal son más pequeños
que lo normal por lo tanto el cuerpo del
bebé no recibe suficiente sangre
si el foramen oval y el conducto
arterioso se cerrarán como normalmente
lo harían
el flujo sanguíneo hacia el cuerpo
disminuiría aún más lo que da como
resultado una situación que pone en
peligro la vida
los síntomas del síndrome del corazón
izquierdo hipoplásico incluyen color de
piel gris o azulado y respiración rápida
cuando el bebé intenta obtener más
oxígeno para el cuerpo sin intervención
quirúrgica esta afección lleva a la
muerte los cirujanos llevan a cabo tres
operaciones independientes para tratar
el síndrome del corazón izquierdo
hipoplásico el objetivo de estas
operaciones es mejorar el flujo de
sangre rica en oxígeno hacia el cuerpo
del bebé
la operación de la etapa 1 llamada
procedimiento de norwich se lleva a cabo
durante la primera semana posterior al
nacimiento durante la operación el
cirujano hace tres cambios principales
primero separa la arteria pulmonar de
las arterias pulmonares derecha e
izquierda
y la conecta a la aorta
inserta un pequeño trozo de tubo
denominado injerto para conectar una
rama de la aorta con la arteria pulmonar
derecha
por último el cirujano quita la pared
entre la aurícula derecha e izquierda
estos cambios aumentan el flujo de
sangre rica en oxígeno desde los
pulmones a través de ambas aurículas
hacia el ventrículo derecho
aumentan el flujo sanguíneo hacia el
cuerpo a través de la nueva aorta e
incrementan el flujo sanguíneo hacia los
pulmones a través del injerto
la operación de la etapa 2 llamada
procedimiento de glenn se lleva a cabo
seis meses después cuando el bebé está
más fuerte
el cirujano quita el injerto que conecta
las ramas de la aorta con la arteria
pulmonar derecha
para reemplazar la función del injerto
el cirujano desconecta la vena cava
superior del corazón y la vuelve a
conectar con la arteria pulmonar derecha
esta conexión permite que la sangre con
bajo contenido de oxígeno que proviene
de la cabeza y los brazos vaya
directamente a los pulmones para
capturar oxígeno
la operación de la tercera etapa
denominada procedimiento de fontán se
lleva a cabo cuando el bebé tiene entre
18 meses y 3 años
el cirujano desconecta la vena cava
inferior del corazón y la vuelve a
conectar a la arteria pulmonar derecha
con el tubo de injerto
esta conexión permite que la sangre con
bajo contenido de oxígeno que proviene
de la parte inferior del cuerpo vaya
directamente a los pulmones para
capturar oxígeno el procedimiento de
fontán completa la reparación quirúrgica
del corazón al alcanzar estos objetivos
entregar sangre rica en oxígeno al
cuerpo a través de la creación de una
aorta nueva y expandida
y crear una nueva vía para que la sangre
con bajo contenido de oxígeno llegue a
los pulmones e impedir que la sangre
rica en oxígeno se mezcle con la sangre
sin oxígeno
estas tres operaciones atenúan la
potencialmente fatal afección causada
por el síndrome del corazón izquierdo
hipoplásico pero no recuperan la
circulación normal a través del corazón
en algunos casos se puede realizar un
trasplante de corazón si hay la
disponibilidad de un corazón donante o
si los cambios de los tres
procedimientos quirúrgicos no funcionan
después de cualquiera de estas
operaciones el niño debe recibir
medicamentos anticoagulantes para evitar
la formación de coágulos de sangre los
niños que reciben trasplantes de corazón
también necesitarán medicamentos para
evitar que su cuerpo rechace el nuevo
corazón es posible que el niño necesite
estos medicamentos durante el resto de
su vida